shutter Home Secretary of Beck Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker the report
published today by Louise Casey
commissioned by the mayor of London into
standards and culture in the
Metropolitan Police Service is thorough
forensic and truly damning
it finds consent is broken management of
the force has failed Frontline policing
especially neighborhood policing has
been de-prioritized and degraded after a
decade of austerity in which the Met has
ended up with 0.7 billion pounds less
than at the beginning of the decade it
finds the Met is failing women and
children that predatory and unacceptable
Behavior have been allowed to flourish
and it finds institutional racism
misogyny and homophobia
baroness Casey pays tribute to the work
police officers do and The Bravery that
they show every day and all of us should
do so because across the country we
depend on the work that police officers
do to keep us all safe catching
criminals protecting the vulnerable
saving lives and we support them in that
vital work but that is what makes it all
the more important that the highest of
standards are maintained and confidence
in those the police surveys sustained
otherwise it lets down communities and
the vital work police officers do we
support the work the new met
commissioner is doing now to start
turning the Met around he and his team
must now go much further in response to
the Casey review but I'm concerned that
the home secretary's statement is
dangerously complacent
astonishingly there is no new action set
out in her response simply words saying
that the Met must change this is a
continuation of the hands-off home
office response that baroness Casey
criticizes in her report
some of the issues raised are particular
to the Met because of its size history
of particular culture where the Home
Secretary and mayor are jointly
responsible for oversight and whether
commissioner is responsible for
delivering but the report also raises
serious wider issues for the home office
the failure to root out officers who've
been involved in domestic abuse sexual
assault also applies in other forces the
failure to tackle culture has gone wrong
in other forces two problems in gwent
Hampshire police Scotland Sussex
leicestershire and more and it is a
disgrace that there still are not
mandatory requirements on vetting and
training underpinned by law that
misconduct systems are still too weak
and I urge her to commit now that anyone
under investigation for domestic abuse
or sexual assault will be automatically
suspended from their role as a police
officer and that anyone with any kind of
history of domestic abuse or sexual
assault will not be given any chance to
become a police officer we need an
urgent overhaul underpinned by law will
she give us that commitment today
for the home office approached more
widely to standards is also failing six
police forces are in so-called special
measures but it is still too easy for
forces to ignore the recommendations
from the inspectorate and the
intervention processes are too weak
where is her plan to turn that around
the report is damning about the
decimation of Frontline policing but
neighborhood policing has been decimated
everywhere not just in the Met six
thousand fewer police officers in
neighborhood teams eight thousand fewer
pcsos just than 2016 and it's worse than
that because offices are routinely
abstracted for other duties so where is
the plan to restore neighborhood
policing labor has set out a plan we
would work with the government on this
but where is the government's plan
the report finds uh is devastating for
the lack of Pub proper public protection
arrangements for women and children who
have been let down but again we know
that across the country prosecutions for
rape and domestic abuse have plummeted
and serious cases have too often been
dismissed so again where is the national
action plan to improve public protection
where is the commitment to specialist
rape investigation units in every Force
specialist domestic abuse experts in 999
control rooms it is not happening and
the findings on institutional misogyny
racism and homophobia are based on
evidence and clear criteria that
baroness Casey has set out for measuring
change with recommendations the Home
Secretary rightly says she wants
discrimination tackled in all its forms
but she has been telling police forces
the opposite and telling them not to
focus on those issues so where is her
plan now to turn that around where is
the home office plan in response to this
on standards on neighborhood policing on
violence against women and girls and on
systemic or institutional discrimination
where are those plans the British
policing model is precious those peel
principles that started in London
policing by consent the police are the
public the public or the police they are
our Guardians not our Gods but that
precious policing model is in Peril the
home office and the Home Secretary are
the custodians of that tradition but the
lack of any plan to restore trust or to
stand things up for policing or to turn
things around is letting everyone down
it's not standing up for the police it's
letting both police and communities down
we is because we believe in policing
because we believe in those peel
principles that we know standing up for
the police also means working with the
police to deliver change and to restore
the trust the confidence and effective
policing that all police officers and
communities properly deserve
foreign